[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe et blue
les négociations entre syndicats et
gouvernement sont délicates sur la
réforme de la sncf
une réforme qui a déclenché une grève
perlée 1 de la part des cheminots là des
arguments du gouvernement est de dire
que c'est l'europe l'europe qui a décidé
de l'ouverture à la concurrence alors
l'europe à postel l'ouverture totale à
la concurrence pour la sncf
la concurrence est ce bon pour l'usager
comment ça se passe chez nos voisins
notamment allemands ce sont les
questions qu'on va se poser aujourd'hui
trois invités monjoin sur ce plateau
jean arthuis bonjour vous êtes écouter
européen du groupe de l'alliance des
démocrates et libéraux pour l'europe un
ancien ministre de l'économie vous êtes
aujourd'hui on peut le dire le
représentant des manuels macron ici au
parlement européen on peut le dire
représentants mais je suis membre en
effet la république en marche voilà
christine leroy danone bonjour vous êtes
députée européenne française du groupe
des socialistes et démocrates membres de
la commission des transports merci
d'avoir accepté mon invitation sans eux
nous ce marché bonjour vous êtes député
français du groupe de la gauche unitaire
européenne d'un membre de la commission
du budget a le seul eurodéputés de la
france est soumise
merci d'avoir accepté mon invitation
mais avant de débattre sur la sncf cap
sur les élections européennes de 2019
en france la république en marche a
donné à coup d'envoi ce week-end des
élections européennes elle a lancé une
grande marche à l'image de ce qui avait
été fait pendant la campagne
présidentielle à plus de mille
événements étaient organisés dans tout
le pays nous avons suivi pendant leur
porte à porte à la ministre chargé des
affaires européennes nathalie loiseau et
la députée amélie de montchalin si les
martel
[Musique]
comme un air de déjà vu
un an après la présidentielle la
république en marche ressort le matériel
de campagne
cette fois pour préparer les élections
européennes vous allez venir les uns
après les autres je vais vous distribuez
effectivement vos feuilles de route sur
papier aujourd'hui certains
travailleront sur smartphone ici dans
l'essonne comme dans toute la france le
parti présidentiel lance une opération
de porte à porte sur le modèle de la
grande marche organisée en 2016 objectif
recueillir les avis des français sur
l'europe pour enrichir le programme
électoral des européennes de l'an
prochain entre populisme et abstention
c'est un scrutin à haut risque pour la
majorité qui mobilise ses ministres et
ses députés sur le terrain et je suis
avec madame l'oiseau qui a misé affaires
européennes oui et si vous avez 5
millions veut bien parler le d'europe
pas toujours facile de parler d'europe
quand l'actualité se concentre sur la
colère des cheminots des fonctionnaires
et des retraités commune avec d'autres
européens
non je trouvais qu'ils ont très
différent de la seule chose que je
pourrais dire c'est qu'on a un peu trop
célia l'europe ans et non surement 6,6
après une matinée de porte-à-porte
ministres et députés sont surprise des
premiers échanges
moi je suis frappé l'europe sociale et
l'environnement revient est vraiment des
thèmes qui reviennent tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps il ya une attente
par rapport à ça et inversement je suis
surprise aussi parce que moi dans ma
tête l'europe c'est la paix c'est ce qui
fait qu'on peut vivre en paix avec nos
voisins qu'on se parle qu'on n'est pas
toujours d'accord mais qu'au moins on a
une vision commune et partagée des
grands enjeux et la paix la sécurité
c'est l'essentiel
c'est pas du tout quelque chose qui
ressort donc ça veut dire que notre
vision parfois de l'image qu'on se donne
nous mêmes des institutions c'est pas
celle que les français mettent en avant
de manière spontanée
cette opération devrait durer cinq
semaines elle sera clôturée par un
discours d' emmanuel macron le 17 avril
au parlement européen
reportage de céline martèle jean arthuis
vous pensez vraiment qu'on peut
mobiliser sur l'europe surtout un an
avant avant le scrutin
ça me paraît très important que les
citoyens européens se saisisse du débat
sur l'europe
qu'attend-t-on de l'europe nous sommes
dans la mondialisation elle crée des
défis sans précédent et des inquiétudes
et bien comment pouvons-nous imaginer
une europe qui prépare notre avenir
une europe qui nous protège c'est ça qui
est au coeur du débat au fond quels sont
les prérogatives de souveraineté qui
exercé par les états membres à l'échelon
national devrait aujourd'hui être
transféré au plan européen pour vous
retrouve effectivement notre
souveraineté en la partageant en matière
de défense de sécurité de climat de
lutte contre le terrorisme mondialisé de
lutte contre les fraudes fiscales contre
les optimisations fiscales les
migrations également autant de sujets
qui justifie un débat christine revault
d'allonnes
olivier faur à dimanche dernier lors du
congrès du ps disait l'objectif pour le
ps est de revenir sur scène avec en
ligne de mire les élections européennes
absolument une europe qui protège
l'europe qui a investi on veut surtout
une europe qui s'intéressent et qui
s'occupe des 500 millions d'européens
pendant très longtemps ce l'europe a été
surtout et on le voit dans les débats et
aussi dans les propositions de la
commission
c'est d'abord la défense du grand marché
de l'union européenne le marché unique
mais les 500 millions d'européens ils
ont quoi pour eux c'était intéressant le
reportage que nous avons vu où on a
entendu que ces français s'intéressaient
aux questions d'europe sociale qu'il ne
voit pas aujourd'hui et c'est un manque
et ça c'était une décision politique de
la majorité politique européenne
aujourd'hui et nous nous sommes très
très heureux très porté sur la question
européenne qui était dans le congrès le
samedi a fait l'objet d'un grande table
ronde avec des partenaires européens qui
sont intervenus de l'ensemble de la
gauche européenne
nous voulons avoir ce débat par des
opérations de porte-à-porte nous en
avons toujours fait et en 2014 c'était
la grande campagne partout au sein de
l'union européenne parce que le parti
socialiste est dans un parti des
socialistes européens
partout au sein de l'union européenne le
noble d'or nous avons tapé à toutes les
portes de l'union européenne nous allons
évidemment le refaire nous allons aussi
poursuivre nos débats mais pour enfin
s'intéresser non pas uniquement à cette
grande question du marché unique ou ceux
qui veulent rejeté l'europe mais
qu'allons nous faire concrètement pour
ses 500 millions d'européens à la france
a soumis c'est quoi la stratégie pour
les européennes on sait que jean luc
mélenchon ne sera ni candidat ni tête de
liste pour l'élection de mes preuves
pour les demies où il ya un vrai clivage
entre mes collègues et moi je pense
qu'il faut mettre un terme à cette
marche conduite par des aveugles et qui
entraîne l'europe vers le précipice
nous pensons que cette europe là n'est
ni démocratique
cette europe là est un danger pour la
planète et cette europe là est à
l'origine des mises en causes profondes
des droits sociaux dans tout
les états membres et puis il y aura je
pense avec la république en marche un
véritable débat vision contre vision
projet contre projet nous ne pensons pas
nous ne croyons pas dans la souveraineté
européenne
nous ne pensons pas par exemple qu'ils
soient ni utile ni nécessaire de
construire une europe de la défense et
je suis certain que le président marc on
en parlera à la semaine prochaine à
strasbourg
nous souhaitons nous garder les éléments
essentiels de notre souveraineté dire
non à l'europe qui est celle du fric
pour que l'europe soit réconcilier avec
sa vocation c'est à dire une europe pour
les peuples
allez on en vit un autre thème du jour
l'europe un post elle l'ouverture totale
à la concurrence pour la sncf ainsi le
gouvernement français justifie la
réforme de la sncf par l'ouverture
prochaine à la concurrence l'allemagne a
connu la libéralisation du rail dès 1994
vétusté dans les infrastructures retards
fréquents la libéralisation à
l'allemande connaît des ratés à sans
parler de la casse sociale l'opérateur
historique
la deutsche bahn détenues par l'état
fédéral va donc investir 1 9 milliard
d'euros pour combler son retard
en revanche sur les longues distances à
la deutsche bahn domine largement ses
concurrents du privé leur portage à
berlin à dresde et leipzig en allemagne
reportage d'alice rougerie
[Musique]
à vos votes
tout fan
allo
à première vue c'est en train classique
l'équivalent de nos ter il relie dresde
en allemagne à une trentaine de petites
villes
sauf que ce train n'appartient pas à la
deutsche bahn la sncf allemande mais à
une compagnie privée pas un souci pour
ses passagers je prends ce train trois
fois par semaine c'est confortable
ponctuelles il ya un peu de retard en
hiver mais ça va c'est une bonne chose
la compétition grâce à ça les prix sont
plus intéressants comme stéphane le
monopole n'est jamais une bonne chose
la concurrence c'est toujours mieux que
quelqu'un qui dirige tout la fin du
monopole
voilà ce qui a été décidé en allemagne à
partir de 1994
aujourd'hui 45% du trafic est géré par
450 entreprises privées parmi elles
transdev filiale française de la caisse
des dépôts
quand elle a remporté le marché sur
cette ligne régionale
ce contrôleur n'a pas hésité à
démissionner de la deutsche bahn
un nouvel emploi plus proche de chez lui
avec le même salaire
j'ai tout de suite candidater pour cette
compagnie quand j'ai entendu parler de
l'appel d'offres j'ai eu de la chance
d'être pris la deutsche bahn
elle est toujours là elle gère les
grandes lignes sept trains flambant
neufs et ses passagers toujours plus
nombreux 2 millions l'année dernière
record de fréquentation la compagnie
publique gère aussi trois quarts du
trafic régional
le reste c'est pour le privé ses côtés
vous avez un train de la deutsche bahn
et de l'autre côté un de notre compagnie
tous les deux sont côte à côte dans la
même gare ici à la cicc un partage des
rails rentable pour l'entreprise
son directeur insiste les passagers
aussi sont gagnants
quand vous êtes en compétition vous
devez trouver le petit plus qui fait de
vous le meilleur c'est vrai que le but
d'un train c'est de vous emmener d'un
point a à un point b
difficile de se démarquer mais si en
allant de a à b vos passagers se sont
mieux sont bien installés c'est ça qui
fait que vous êtes le meilleur
sauf que ce petit plus ce n'est pas
toujours là dans les campagnes sur les
plus petites lignes
c'est même tout le contraire le service
s'est dégradée parole d'usagé ce n'est
pas ponctuelle il y à des annulations
ces salles parfois c'est plein c'est pas
fial bref ça ne me plaît pas trop cette
compagnie roule avec du matériel
vraiment vétuste matériel ça se sent
honda ses cheveux braun dire aux banques
mais ils ont remporté l'appel d'offres
pour gérer cette ligne plusieurs années
c'est dommage
pas mieux côté personnel notamment pour
ce conducteur un ancien du public
il regrette son statut de cheminot c'est
devenu plus difficile avec la réforme
les conditions de travail se sont
dégradées à cause de cela il y a moins
de conducteurs des places non pourvus
des emplois moins attractif aujourd'hui
et des coupes importantes dans les
effectifs
ce syndicat dénonce la casse sociale de
la réforme agraire notre plus grande
problématique c'est la destruction
d'emplois ces vingt dernières années
on n'ose pas il y avait 400 mille
cheminots à l'époque quand on cumule et
les sociétés des deux allemagnes
aujourd'hui on est en dessous des 200
milles donc moitié moins de salariés
pour toujours autant de travail
réponse de la deutsche bahn à ces
critiques
un plan massif d'investissements plus de
9 milliards d'euros sont débloqués pour
moderniser le réseau
cela comprend aussi dix neuf mille
embauches rien que pour cette année
[Musique]
voilà reportage en allemagne d'alice
rougerie question toute simple quel
scénario
le gouvernement français devrait il
privilégia pour la sncf un scénario à
l'allemande comme on l'a vu dans le
reportage où le modèle italien ou où la
concurrence sur le réseau tgv a mené la
diminution des prix du billet du
voyageur de 2 30% à une augmentation du
trafic de 20% et division par 2 du
trafic aérien entre entre milan ou rome
ou alors le modèle britannique a où tout
a été privatisée où apparemment ça fait
un effet repoussoir jean arthuis quel
modèle il s'agit pas de privatiser
il s'agit de réformer et d'assurer une
performance
l'europe a bon dos on dit voilà l'europe
oblige à la concurrence en fait l'europe
a souhaité assurer la mobilité l'inter
opérabilité qu'un trains puissent
franchir les frontières sans difficulté
et il faut bien reconnaître que la sncf
en france est en difficulté et on ne
peut pas la laisser en l'état
donc il s'agit à la fois de respecter
des orientations prises sur le plan
européen et de prendre des dispositions
pour une performance
la concurrence peut avoir des effets de
stimulation j'ai vu des situations
insoutenables en france on a essayé de
développer le fret avec l'ouverture à la
concurrence le fret par la sncf c'est au
surplus une façon de respecter des
exigences écologiques d'éviter les
émissions de co2 j'ai vu dans l'ouest la
france puisque je suis élu dans l'ouest
de la france une société qui s'appelle
combiwest qui était dans cette logique
de concurrence sur le fret est bien la
sncf bloquer les réseaux et cette
société a été conduite à la faillite
cette situation ne peut pas durer
j'ai vu la sncf également surfacturé des
travaux d'entretien de voix à la limite
du supportable par les collectivités
territoriales donc c'est en cela que la
concurrence peut avoir des vertus
je pense que c'est l'intérêt
des contribuables l'intérêt des usagers
l'intérêt de l'économie et l'intérêt
environnemental
nous avons besoin d'une sncf compétitive
et l'ouverture à la concurrence ne doit
pas effrayer les régions elles mêmes
sont très désireuses qu'on ouvre à la
concurrence
les crises in revault d'allonnes
l'europe un post elle une concurrence
totale et absolument pas le quatrième
paquet ferroviaire qui a été adoptée et
d'ailleurs pas voté par tous les groupes
et tous les députés en tout cas nous les
socialistes français sur la question
les obligations de service public nous
n'avons pas voté pour ce texte ce qui
est préconisé c'est effectivement une
questions d'interopérabilité s'assurer
qu'elles les trains puissent circuler
partout au sein de l'union européenne
avec des systèmes techniques harmonisée
des rails de même taille
c'est un détail mais en même temps si on
n'a pas ça on peut pas fonctionner de
cette manière là et sur les questions
liées à l'ouverture à la concurrence il
y a des options possibles il y a la
possibilité de rester en obligations de
service public et de maintenir par
attribution directe à un seul opérateur
c'est dans le texte où il y a le
principe de l'open access c'est à dire
la concurrence totale comme le cas du
royaume uni où on a vu les prix flambent
et pour les usagers
mais ce qui doit nous prions pour ou
lopsi loin donc elles ont choisi sur la
concurrence laurence total c'est le
gouvernement ce n'est pas l'europe c'est
pas l'europe mais c'est pas dans le
texte dans le taxi à des options et il
ya des possibilités et moi je me
souviens du gouvernement français
précédent puisque nous l'avons votée
sous le gouvernement de monsieur manuel
valls les préconisations de la france
c'était de dire ceux concernant les
lignes à grande vitesse donc les lignes
tgv il faut absolument maintenir
l'obligation de service public parce
qu'il est inacceptable de d'opérer une
fracture territoriale si un certain
nombre de lignes considérés comme non
rentables n'était plus opéré par un
opérateur privé qui ne verraient pas son
intérêt c'était la position de la france
jusqu'en mai 2017 c'est est ce que nous
défendions et ce qui compte ce n'est pas
concurrence ou pas concurrencer pas le
postulat économique
ce qui compte c'est avoir un service de
transport ferroviaire fiables sûres et à
des coûts qui sont supportables par les
usagers et surtout on protège
le statut de tous ceux qui travaillent
dans le secteur ferroviaire
les cheminots comme tous les ans aux
marges et on a vu le reportage
l'allemagne a libéralisé ces chemins de
feria il ya 25 ans cette concurrence
est-ce qu'elle apportera en france un
meilleur service pour les usagers selon
vous certainement pas mon n'a d'ailleurs
l'exemple anglais qui monte à glv mois
un tas d par votre oeuvre
mais kim on est rassuré montre à quel
point le service n'est ni régulier ni
sur et n'apportent pas le minimum de
confort qu'attendent les usagers mais je
veux quand même dire que l'union
européenne et la commission européenne
est devenue aujourd'hui la grande
inspiratrice des politiques nationales à
travers notamment les réformes
structurelles et nous ne devons pas
oublier par exemple que le marché du
travail en france a été profondément
réformé sur injonction de bruxelles
quel est l'objectif il s'agit je crois
par tous de mettre en cause des tas de
faire place nette pour les acteurs du
marché
parce que lorsque l'état se retire les
besoins eux demeurent et à ce moment là
vous avez l'offensive des acteurs privés
s'agissant des votes
je ne souhaitais pas en parler mais il
est vrai que notre groupe a été celui
qui s'est opposé systématiquement à tous
les paquets ferroviaires
nous en sommes au kac ayem mais et je
suis au regret de dire à ma chère
collègue que si nous mettons de côté
l'inter aurait à 0 père à billy n'est
pas se rassurent lançant sur l'ensemble
des paquets ferroviaires
le groupe socialiste a voté pour et nous
avons nous jean luneau mélenchon et moi
voté contre il faut et je te rebond
rapide quatrième paquet hier
non mais ce que ce soit l'ex arrière
dire que la sncf est quand même
franchement en difficulté et ses dix
milliards et demi de subventions chaque
année chez 3 milliards pour le régime
des retraites c'est une dette qui est à
50 milliards
on pouvait pas continuer ainsi et quels
sont les axes et pas c'est pas l'europe
qui qui qui est le déterminant dans
cette affaire on ne pouvait pas
continuer ainsi rien vrai sujet dans les
préconisations qui sont faites en disant
on va réformer la sncf qui était
aujourd'hui 3 epic un épique de tête et
des epic pour les gares pour l'opérateur
et pour le réseau sauf que ça on ne peut
pas le faire à l'échelle de l'union
européenne c'est l'union européenne qui
avait dit il faut absolument distinguer
le réseau de l'opérateur
ou alors vous ne pourrez pas mettre en
place la concurrence je ne comprends pas
la proposition si ce n'est même s'ils ne
veulent pas le reconnaître qu'il y a
l'idée de la privatisation de la sncm
mais on a été bon reconnaissez que c'est
comme ça qu'on a tué combiwest par
exemple que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
c'est parce que la sncf à la fois
opérateurs et gestionnaires ce réseau a
empêché combi ouais je veux revenir sur
la question de ce marché à l'hameçon
jeux sont quand même assez étonné je
vois les tentatives désespérées de faire
en sorte de dire que l'europe n'a rien à
voir avec cela mais nous savons tous que
l'union n'y pas que derrière on voit
l'union européenne est pas dire aux
galeries chagnon et bernie tueur jeunes
à la concurrence simplement que avec le
gouvernement avec ou sans l'europe et
les régions des lacs rond vont plus loin
ils vont beaucoup plus loin par la
création par exemple d'une société
anonyme qui effectivement là sont drôles
et par l'état là dessus nous avons des
relais par l'état comme la deutsche bahn
mais il n'y a rien à voir entre le
modèle allemand est le modèle français
jean arthuis parlais tout à l'heure des
régions françaises
mais on ne peut pas comparer aujourd'hui
les länder allemands venant des régions
du commerce certains défier la réalité
c'est qu'en allemagne
l'état reste actionnaire à 100% ce que
va se faire qu ce que va faire et
l'opérateur historique de cheval n'a pas
de jordan qui comprend l'importance de
garder le rôle de l'intérieur les taons
francs elle va rester actionnaire à 100
pour être tous et si vous avez conçu et
géré les présidents de région ils vont
tous vous dire à l'exception peut-être
de celui de la bretagne que vraiment ils
n'en peuvent plus
car lorsqu'il demande des comptes aux
concessionnaires qui est la sncf c'est
la croix et la bannière
et on en short ma fille n'est donc s'il
ya un peu de concurrence peut-être que
ça introduirait un peu de trop la
finalité c'est la vente à la découpe du
patrimoine français ne les intéresse pas
dire ça alors là vraiment c'est
incantatoires mais c'est encore les
barrages et des marches qu'engage on
peut faire le parallèle avec les
barrages hydrauliques
actuellement qui sont privatisés il faut
se poser aussi la question pourquoi est
ce que la france entrent aujourd'hui
dans un processus de privatisation des
barrages hydrauliques je sais qu'on va
sur ce que je ne comprends pas moi c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement s'obstine pour
ce qui concerne les grandes lignes je ne
parle pas des lignes régionales à mettre
en accès total et ouvert à la
concurrence le fameux open access et
pourquoi sur un certain nombre de lignes
pour s'assurer qu'ils aient à aucun
moment une fracture territoriale liée à
un manque de rentabilité économique
et bien oui mais sauf que s'il ya lieu
déjà la position du gouvernement reste
sur l'open access ch alors que le cahier
des charges pourraient très bien géré ce
qu'il y a des obligations dans ce public
sur ces mineurs je pense qu'il faudra
être très attentif au cahier des charges
par exemple si vous avez vous devrez la
concurrence paris bordeaux il ya des
trains qui s'arrêteront à poitiers à
angoulême open access il n'ya plus le
occasions dont il n'ya plus obligation
de service et de leurs services publics
pourquoi ils ne l'acceptent pas de faire
cette petite ouverture à l'obligation de
service public sur ses grandes lignes
vous le savez très bien je pense que la
grande vitesse servent aussi à des
personnes pour aller de leur domicile à
leur emploi elles sont aussi utiles pour
cela et c'est on lui demandera de faire
des contre l'intérêt des usagers
il s'agit de répondre à la demande des
usagers je ne doute pas que les cahiers
des charges notamment ceux qui seront
mis au point par les régions qui ont
compétence en matière ferroviaire de
transport de personnes je suis persuadé
qu'on trouvera les bons équilibres tout
cas au parlement européen on a mis trois
ans à discuter du quatrième paquet
ferroviaire
là on a un système régis net et par
ordonnance
on a insisté
où les syndicats sont entendus mais en
même temps que le texte sur les
ordonnances et présenté au niveau du
parlement
ce ne sont pas des conditions et de
concertation vous reconnais dernier les
trouver un consensus
alors même qu'il y aller on retient un
texte adopté je veux dire le coût social
de tout cela parce qu'on a entendu on a
entendu le représentant des salariés en
allemagne wolman il y a eu cent mille
emplois qui ont été sacrifiés en
allemagne et combien taudis à gré du
fait que dit et transports je ne crois
pas du tout à la casse sociale et
souliers le pragmatisme de la sncf parce
que la sncf c'est aussi le transport
routier transport routier et calberson
que devenu geodis et quel est le
principal opérateur en roumanie
notamment ses geodis alors je voudrais
qu'on est un peu de cohérence et qu' on
est une vision globale de ce qu'on peut
opérer au plan européen
je fais l'hypothèse que certains profits
de geodis en roumanie ou dans les pays
de l'est de l'europe servent à compenser
les déficits de la sncf en france vous
avez l'air de la forme ferroviaire on
aurait pu en proposer une autre et nous
si ça ce que nous on ne peut pas jean
arthuis avoir une vision budgétaire de
la vie et de la vie des gens donc
lorsqu'on tard et vous savez le budget
ce n'est que la répartition de la charge
entre les membres d'une communauté
et bien moi j'attache du prix que ce
budget soit l'isi nous avons on vous
mettra pas d'accord ça fait partie du
des du débat on termine par le redis
arrivera quand on termine par notre
rubrique de fact checking le 25 mai 2018
une date essentiel dans la protection
des données à ce jour là le règlement
européen sera applicable à la commission
européenne a promis à le changement le
plus important en matière de
confidentialité des données depuis 20
ans mais dans les faits protégera t'il
vraiment notre vie privée sur le net dès
le 25 mai c'est checkpoint préparé par
jean claude vercey
pour le 25 mai la commission européenne
promet le changement le plus important
en matière de confidentialité des
données depuis vingt ans les gens auront
le droit de dire oui ou non dès qu'il
s'agit d'utiliser leurs données le
nouveau règlement général de protection
des données c'est son nom oblige les
entreprises à révéler quelles données
personnelles sont collectées comment
elles sont utilisées et de quelle
manière elles sont sécurisés ce
règlement garantie des droits précis aux
citoyens un site ou un service en ligne
qui veut utiliser de données devra
obtenir notre accord écrit un enfant ne
pourra pas s'inscrire sur un réseau
social sans l'accord des parents
l'internaute dispose d'un droit à
l'oubli ou faire disparaître ces données
personnelles et enfin nous pourrons être
défendus par des associations dans le
cadre d'une action de groupe mais
plusieurs obstacles risquent de freiner
la mise en oeuvre de ces protections
ainsi le règlement réduit l'usagé des
cookies qui espionnent les consommateurs
mais paradoxalement cela favorise les
entreprises qui n'utilisent pas ces
cookies mais piste directement les
identités des internautes et ce sera
tout bénéfice pour les gaffes à les
apple amazon et autres qui contournent
ainsi le règlement seront aussi
favoriser les acteurs mondiaux qui
fournissent les services gratuits aux
consommateurs on pense à google ou
facebook qui obtiennent plus facilement
le droit d'utiliser les données des
internautes qu'un quelconque site de
vente en ligne
un autre maillon faible de la protection
des données et l'impréparation des
entreprises
60% d'entre elles risquent tout
simplement de ne pas être prête pour le
25 mai tu es le maillon faible au revoir
ainsi plus de la moitié des applications
du magasin en ligne les store de google
ne sont pas conformes aux règlements et
enfin où en sont les législations
nationales
à ce jour seuls trois pays sont
conformes à la réglementation l'autriche
l'allemagne et la slovaquie
alors les données seront elles mieux
protéger le 25 mai prochain
c'est partiellement vrai jean arthuis
voulu réagir sur la protection des
données très rapidement oui une europe
qui nous protège en matière de numérique
y'a que l'europe qui peut y parvenir les
états à l'échelon national n'ont plus la
main donc que les états membres aillent
très vite valider les rapports que nous
avons votée au parlement européen sur le
gr et sur ipv6 parce qu'on les attend
toujours et le rhône où nous avons fait
notre travail nous avons lavabo leurs
maris protège personne n'y croit plus
parce que aujourd'hui tout le monde est
fragilisé par les politiques européennes
vous mettra pas d'accord en tout cas
c'est le débat c'est la fin de repas bio
merci d'avoir accepté mon attitude
l'invitation c'était passionnant merci à
vous à nous avoir suivis bonne suite des
programmes matures les chaînes
parlementaires et la rtbf bail
[Musique]